carrusel de las artes
[Música]
maría carolina piña
reciban un cordial saludo desde la
ciudad de perpiñán hoy tengo el agrado
de presentarles nuestro programa
carrusel de las artes desde el festival
de fotoperiodismo más importante del
mundo
[Música]
regresa el festival visa publimar con 25
exposiciones sobre el estado del mundo
ucrania y otros conflictos graves y
urgentes son el plato fuerte de esta
edición mostrar las condiciones de vida
en los centros de detención para mujeres
en américa latina es la misión que se ha
planteado la fotógrafa venezolana ana
maría arévalo su serie de días eternos
se muestra en perpiñán y nosotros
conversamos con ella la emergencia
climática es otra de las temáticas
cruciales en vida publimar una de las
muestras pone el acento en la rápida
desaparición de la biodiversidad por
culpa del hombre y en nuestra crónica
musical nos colamos en el taller de
trabajo de un creador singular julian os
el crea piezas únicas inspiradas en los
años 70 para conocidos cantantes y
artistas del mundo del espectáculo
[Música]
la fotografía de prensa es reina en vida
paul y más este festival la que llega a
su edición número 34 reúne este año los
trabajos de fotoperiodismo más
relevantes del mundo por supuesto la
invasión rusa a ucrania es uno de los
temas centrales y en perpiñán conocimos
a uno de los autores de las fotos más
desgarradoras tomadas en territorio
ucraniano
[Música]
durante 20 días euro animal o letra y su
colega mit isla fisher nov fueron
testigos de esa lluvia de bombas sobre
la población civil es lo que muestra su
foto reportaje presentado en perpiñán
una serie que comienza con la imagen de
una niña sobre una camilla que moriría
poco tiempo después esa y otras fotos le
dieron la vuelta al mundo
[Música]
cuando llegamos a mario pool una hora
antes de que estallara la guerra uno de
nuestros objetivos era documentar la
situación de los hospitales me acuerdo
claramente del caso de esa niña vestida
con su peana se llamaba eba tenía tres
años y medio fue muy difícil presenciar
esas escenas
[Música]
bien
eugeni malo let k pudo viajar a perpiñán
pero espera continuar su trabajo
periodístico en ucrania foto centro
todos los días hay muchas cosas que
contar porque la guerra no se ha
acabando además es mi país es me
gustaría que esto no estuviera pasando
la verdad es que el hombre definiría no
tomar estas fotos tengo amigos y
parientes en esa guerra incluso mis
padres ahora son refugiados
la serie de un animal o letra y mit isla
chernoff es una de las cinco muestras
sobre ucrania presentadas en el festival
de fotoperiodismo visa pour l'image de
perpiñán el director del festival john
howard lowe manuel & clyde sounds
chernoff y malo les dieron el golpe
periodístico del año con sus fotografías
en mario pool son imágenes de padres que
ven morir a sus hijos en los brazos es
terrible
así es el fotoperiodismo porque así va
el mundo en ucrania han muerto 20
periodistas desde la anexión de crimea a
rusia lo mismo en méxico en brasil es
una profesión difícil pero indispensable
o sea mente 16 mesa mecanismos am
[Música]
villapol y más presenta exposiciones
sobre los grandes acontecimientos que
tuvieron lugar en este último año pero
también realidades más silenciosas la
condición de las mujeres en las cárceles
latinoamericanas es en lo que ha
trabajado la venezolana ana maría
arévalo quien nos espera en su
exposición
gracias a anna maría arévalo gocen por
estar con nosotros en carrusel de las
artes anamaría el año pasado recibiste
el premio camille de paga aquí en
perpiñán por esta serie de fotografías
que se llama días eternos que realizaste
en tres países latinoamericanos y este
año el público puede apreciar tu trabajo
que cuentan esas fotografías que fueron
tomadas en prisiones y en centros de
detención para mujeres mira este trabajo
se ama días eternos empezó en 2017 y
cuenta un poco la vida cotidiana de las
mujeres que están en centros de
detención preventiva y cárceles del
salvador venezuela y guatemala en
cuentan como los días de ellas este se
repiten una y otra vez y el tiempo para
ella no pasa a menos de que llegue la
libertad digámoslo así pasan sus días
extrañando a sus hijos que están afuera
esperan a que vengan los abogados que
nunca llegan y muchas de ellas no tienen
agua medicinas comidas cosas básicas
para vivir entonces esperan también este
momento de la visita o este momento de
recibir sus paquetes
lo que cuando cuenta en un gran
sufrimiento encuentran una gran
vulnerabilidad de unas mujeres que están
siendo tratadas en condiciones
infrahumanas en estos países y en muchos
otros países de latinoamérica que
todavía me quedan por descubrir y bueno
y eso es lo que pueden ver en la en el
trabajo en guatemala la particularidad
es que además de que es un país
hermosísimo y pluricultural tiene este
problema que cuando una mujer indígena
va a la cárcel no habla castellano
entonces en los centros de tensiones
conseguí un montón de mujeres indígenas
que no saben por qué están detenidas o
si saben por qué están detenidas pero el
abogado no habla su idioma o el juez no
habla su idioma entonces necesitan pasar
como por muchos otros canales el proceso
se hace mucho más lento y el retraso
procesal es mucho mayor para estas
mujeres y es algo que pone de relieve en
tus fotografías el tema de la maternidad
es decir que son mujeres que comparten
esa condición de estar en prisión en
prisión preventiva con sus bebés con sus
hijos y ahí también hay una condición de
vulnerabilidad estos tres países donde
trabajan hay solamente una cárcel donde
hay centros maternos
para toda la población que son miles de
mujeres casi todas madres segundo
para las mujeres es muy digamos cuando
hablo con ellos ellas me dicen que
tener a sus hijos dentro de la cárcel es
algo que es como un revitalizante porque
están buenos pero al mismo tiempo
también es muy duro para ellas porque el
mundo sus hijos no conocen la libertad
muchas de ellas dieron a luz estando en
prisión y sus hijos no saben que es el
mundo entonces el tema de la maternidad
es lo más fuerte yo creo para una mujer
impresión cómo te sientes presentando
este trabajo aquí en perpiñán y se
siente súper bien estar aquí además de
este año son fotógrafos y personas que
quieren ver un cambio en lo que son
personas que están haciendo algún tipo
no sé si llamarlo activismo porque no sé
si a activismo pero si quieren mostrar
una realidad para provocar un cambio y
un impacto no que es lo que creo que es
lo más importante que podemos hacer
nosotros bueno te agradecemos muchísimo
que haya compartido este momento con
carrusel de las artes para hablar de
esta serie días eternos que revisaste en
venezuela el salvador y guatemala
muchísimas gracias en amarillo gracias
gracias gracias
[Música]
pixar publi más están en una vitrina
para uno de los problemas más graves que
enfrenta la humanidad como lo es el
cambio climático y una serie en
particular aquí en perpiñán aborde el
problema de la desaparición de las
especies animales por causa de la
actividad humana se llama la sexta
extinción del francés allan ernesto
retratos de animales que miran al
espectador como queriendo decirnos algo
alan iud presenta casi 40 especies
vulnerables o en vías de extinción esta
serie nos habla de una nueva extensión
animal en curso que tiene al hombre como
protagonista
[Música]
olancho las frescas y en extensión el
gran problema con la que llaman la sexta
extinción es que las cinco primeras
fueron causadas por catástrofes
naturales
en cambio la sexta que está
produciéndose debido a la actividad
humana la contaminación la deforestación
la industrialización los últimos 40 años
en europa han desaparecido 500 millones
de pájaros en 70 años 70 por ciento de
los animales vertebrados se han perdido
en todo el mundo es decir es una
destrucción acelerada e inédita casi
todas las steel antes tuvieron lugar
durante siglos pero ahora la
biodiversidad se está reduciendo en
tiempo récord
cada retrato en blanco y negro son cara
a cara como una especie animal que
quizás desaparezca de la faz de la
tierra en poco tiempo no hay produzca la
creo que el blanco y negro tiene algo
que nos permite apreciar la misma
esencia de cada animal y su mirada
particular lo que me interesaba era
compartir esta experiencia de la vida
salvaje con el público y crear una
emoción mi intención nuestra selección
es más bien que los animales se
conviertan en amigos para todo el que
vea estas fotos
me tomo
[Música]
luego de este recorrido por las
exposiciones de vida paul y más vamos a
dar un salto a parís para conocer un
artista que navega entre música moda y
estética de los años 70 nuestras cámaras
se colaron en su taller es un reportaje
de natale olivares y
janice watson aquí tenemos una camisa
con cuello o rabo que un gran clásico de
los años 60 es un modelo inspirado por
reina visi el vocalista del grupo the
kings
julia gonzález tenía un sueño y lo
volvió realidad crear una línea de ética
hecha por y para la música como lo logro
diseñando ropa para artistas y
reciclando géneros produciendo solo por
pedidos para no desperdiciar y hacer
repartos en bicicleta su marca se llama
but money is
los enteros y sus bienes al seguro de
las grandes producciones después de un
desfile o de una colección nosotros le
damos una segunda vida el proceso
consiste en reciclar lo resucitarlo en
prenda como por ejemplo este terciopelo
cotelé no margine para confeccionar un
pantalón con talla alta me inspiré del
primer álbum concepto del artista
francis sears book melody nelson
cabecita final al final este es el
resultado en pantalón talla alta con
bolsillos de parches aparentes
pero porque los años 60 y 70 una época
en que él no había nacido porque detrás
de este taller está su abuela paulette
su verdadera musa y asociada
fue mi abuela quien me dio el gusto por
la contracultura y la estética de los
años 60 y 70 él contó cómo lo había
vivido y toda la admiración que le tenía
esa juventud que revoluciona la sociedad
cuestionando la autoridad del mercado la
sexualidad el medio ambiente el uso de
drogas y utilizando un estilo de
vestimenta la ropa es un marcador social
si no se lleva a esa época en la sangre
la efervescencia social cultural y
musical se ve en sus estilos su última
colección es una colaboración con la
cantante británica test pax para cada
canción del álbum
con una prenda
[Música]
de spark es un artista que conozco desde
hace años siempre pensamos que sería
genial compartir parte de la historia
juntos así que creamos un artefacto que
llevaba el adn de la marca de good
morning keys y el adn de la propia test
park de su música decidimos unir
nuestras fuerzas para crear 30 canciones
y 30 piezas una conexión perfecta entre
declaraciones musicales y las de good
morning kiss
[Música]
sin la música no hay prendas así de
sencillo julius él tiene esa idea muy
clara y lo han seguido en este proyecto
artistas muy famosos como por ejemplo la
cantante clara 12 años
en 2021 tuve la oportunidad de crear la
ropa de escena de la gira declaró
anuncian y el respiro tu puedes ver mis
dibujos y ante las arriba del escenario
con los músicos más recientemente creado
la propia de la misma vista de william
de frontenis y supe que se vistieron con
la marca del bourbon y kiss en los
escenarios de glastonbury en reino unido
y el festival primavera de barcelona y
esto me conmueve enormemente
[Música]
gracias natal y olivares y con esto
ponemos punto final este programa
especial carrusel de las artes que les
presentamos desde pepiño en el corazón
del país catalán francés muchísimas
gracias por su sintonía y hasta la
próxima jaua
[Música]
bueno
d
amor
[Música]
no no
ay